As so often the case with our data, some entries
or documents will have fields that other do not. In
any project, a data model usually goes through several literations.
MongoDB was designed to address both of these issues by providing
a flexible schema that deals well with both individual documents
that vary in the fields they contain as well as
the schema for our entire collection needing to change. Let's
take a look at person info box data, as an example.
Now for nearly everyone, it probably makes sense to
include fields for birth and death dates. Maybe nationality and
even profession, but not everyone will have held office, and
not everyone is associated with a political party. And even
if we're talking about people who are not famous,
some people will have spouses. Some will have more than
one. And others won't. Some will have children and some
will not. Leaving aside the question of what is the
right data model for person data. In MongoDB we can
represent each person using the fields that are appropriate to them
even if some person documents contain fields that others don't have.
MongoDB's indexing system and query execution system take this into account.
So we can query a people collection for people with
two or more children, and it will work as expected retrieving
only data for people that have two or more entries in
the array that serves as the value for the children field.
Ignoring documents with fewer As well as documents that don't
have a children field at all. What this also means is
that it's easy to evolve your scheme as new needs emerge
or more data becomes available. It's a simple matter to begin
adding documents to a collection that have new fields you now
want to track or to change the way you model existing
fields. As an example of this, let's take a look at
the dbpedia page, that describes the data sets that are available.
Now, if I scroll down this page. And, I've already
done that here, we have an example for city data.
So, so far we've looked at automobile data, person data
and now, city data, from the info-box data set. And, I'm
showing this example to illustrate the fact that the scheme
for city info boxes has evolved. And, we can see that
in this old example for Innsbruck. And comparing it to
the new example for Innsbruck and if you look through this
data there are a couple of places where
the data has changed. There's no mayor listed here
as there is here and while there's no time
zone listed in the old form of the data.
The time zone for central and day light
savings time are listed here. Small differences, but these
are the type of subtle changes that we would
expect to see in a schema that is evolving.